chimène j'aimerais qu'on met entre nous
parce que c'est une chanson qui est très
importante pour moi d'accord parce que
c'est sur cette chanson que j'ai flippé
non mais c'est sur cette chanson que ce
jour
j'ai fêté le troisième parc oui tu
attends a donné quoi si j'ai fêté un
truc super intendance cette chanson oui
mais quoi j'avais acheté mon premier
vélo
koné fois c'est vrai hier c'était assez
émouvant c'est parti
ces parties qui commence
[Musique]
donnant ce
il se charge entre nous
entre nous ce nombre on sait le temps qu
il
donnera 4 mai
rendez vous
entre nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maxime
même ma grande surprise
[Musique]
j'atteins à vous remercie d'être là où
souffle un énorme bisou et je sais que
entre nous
alors et alors il faut alors je vous
prends de l'epr cc pour chimène et
chimène je te sens tu ferais mieux c'est
la première fois que ton père vient de
voir
merci il n'est pas depuis longtemps en
plus moi je pense s'est manifesté en
grèce marcy mattioni moment je sais qu
il est beau gosse a perdu les jeunes il
est frais et sans rigoler les rams
aurait dit moi ça fait jamais
l'attention tu le touches pas celui-là
[Rires]
je cite il nous a dit que entre nous
c'est une chance on comptait beaucoup
pour lui c'est vrai un coût et il avait
envie de la chanter ce soir bas où
j'aurai du mal
j'aurais dû match de mon joker sentez
vous chantez des compagnies non c'est
pour ça que je demande un joker en tout
cas chez manon voulait de faire cette
surprise yonnaise c'est une super belle
surprise demain il ya de vrais atouts en
album qui sort et ton père voulait faire
un gros bisou avant voilà cet album qui
va fêter tennis est en carrière